more than 18 points per game well he has
to shoot the ball now without bradley
bill
around he's got to shoot the basketball
and
look he is very worthy of getting 25
points wide like dario saric would be
out on the court bridges sets up for the
corner three won't get it but eighteen
inside with the offensive rebound back
to rubio
coming off a solid three-point shooting
game and he followed it up with a
three-point hit there so like what jerry
and grant could do too i like his length
and i like the way he defends
yes smith has it swatted by payne
they're perfect 15 for 15 at the line
and a turnover on the inbounds
bridges tries for three and connects so
that's a five-point possession i mean
these guys are used to playing on the
court
in these similar situations kale
showing some aggressiveness now the last
two trips pushes the lead back
double figures my father's just more
than just my dad he's someone really
special
and you know we've done several
conversations with phil schneer
and bobby dandridge these final 12
minutes
is as much as ayden takes a pretty feet
over the top of cameron paint but this
is as much about
getting your defense set and prepared
for what's coming on sunday game on
sunday so
you're exactly right and and again it's
the growth of this young team it's the
understanding that he throws up some
shots that make you scratch your head
but
is successful more often than not ayton
again
being spoon fed if this fourth quarter
started
they all type basketball and again it's
the environment that the nba has created
for its players and deandre he's going
to lead the league in three-point
percentage cam continues to shoot the
three ball
extremely well
[Applause]
dodged on the drive well defended on a
beautiful recovery there from bridges
sweet spots and he has definitely been a
huge addition for their team
has had a good start booker
looking from deep and likes the results
here's hardaway junior who like booker
and ayton run into foul trouble and now
he runs into
mikhail bridges and bridges takes the
payoff pass from ricky for his first
points just
showing everybody he will be first team
all defense not
used to maybe playing having these job
descriptions
what while devin and deandre ayton was
out that's a heck of a pass there though
from ricky rubio shot clock down at
three
bridges squeezing leonard and ultimately
comes up with a steal
i think kawhi leonard is going to find
out that mikhail bridges is a
a future first team all defenders
rubio very clever with the basketball
finds booker gets it inside to wait and
eight now with five with the six for the
sun
sun's come back the other way the
clippers go from offense to defense
bridges
to rubio flings a three and knocks it in
counted in a foul
this is just this is you know not known
as a great shooter
but he can make shot
booker catch and shoot three and knocks
it in you mentioned it in our open
he's not just a shooter he is a scorer
as it'll take a little while to get his
legs back hawaii leonard misses short
well this team will be very very happy
to have lou back
we know we all know what he can do
usually the rule is no sweat no shoot
it is usually not a problem for lou
williams he misses there
another three by the suns and devin
booker
is warming up booker draws the
assignment of kawhi leonard on the other
side which is interesting get a good
look at landry shamit there
nice play defensively by cameron payne
he'll take it back the other way
and lay four points three rebounds a
couple of assists
payne feeling good lets it fly and
knocks in a deep
three is going to call his own number
it's around george in the corner to
bridges for three
and a great play by booker great finish
by bridge
rubio shadowed by jackson
leonard invites booker baseline he
decides to pull the trigger on a three
and knock it in five of a kind
for devin six to play
[Applause]
booker this is for the win got it
wow
[Applause]
that is good for sure what a shot
devin booker today
puts the suns now 3-0
in the bubble
big matchup for two of the three
unbeaten teams in the bubble is ayton
right to the rim nice defense there from
the rookie cam johnson to force
another pacers miss rubio on the drive
again contact and ricky
amazing how a big time win
can elevate you
cameron payne's checked into the game
indiana has missed their last seven
meanwhile it's a 17-0
scoring run here for the sun
well you know tj's getting a dose of
what it is to be a star right he's
getting a dose of what it is to beat
devin book double team uh very
aggressive wants to get around you
at 12 points in the victory against
orlando
pretty pass inside to hayton who will
look for the and one
his first team second well again
they're recalled released in the paint
that's an easy one there brockton
got inside ayton recovers defensively
and then the long rebound tapped back
out boy the suns catch a huge break
there
catch and shoot three for cam and down
it goes
amazing how that works right hey man i
need more of that
inside shot clock gotta let it fly
carter just does get it off and some
afternoon banking in the bubble the
floor there by a holiday yeah i'll be a
little bit overly aggressive at the end
of that
call
[Music]
to follow number three every holiday he
just got that
out of his hand shot clock expired
[Music]
[Applause]
here's brogdon great recovery gets the
block signature moved to his left
i really love how deandre is thinking
the game he could have forced that but
the time is more important right now
and it led to another booker jump
[Music]
yeah because of that it's really i mean
how do you even figure out
or try to maneuver they've not
found a way to get the ball into deandre
ayton just yet
finally they're able to as he takes a
beautiful pass over the top from devin
booker despite the double team
very thin inside and any kind of switch
off he has the advantage been
on the attack early
[Applause]
six points booker on a drive and a
pretty finish for devin booker thursday
where he had
five threes 21st time this season that
he's done that is book
able to connect payne unable to get it
to him
yeah he's got to really be careful and
try to get him the ball
drops it off to d.a finds book gets up
top
devin booker uh you gotta respect that
man we milly can shoot gentlemen
he can elevate
kickball was a call they got the reset
on the shot clock and
he has that advantage down there he just
really got it easy right now
double team they swing it across to the
open shooter cam johnson
makes him pay with another triple with a
hundred
three-point hits stolen away by rubio
up ahead to cam and the flush
that's what i'm talking about on the run
finishing strong cam job knocked away
there by shards
ricky did a good job that time he didn't
really stand there and take the hit
totally
basically backed up and a quick 7-2
oklahoma city lead
booker on the drive goes glass
mentally you just let you guard down
this is something the sons are going to
really fight here in the first half
book on the turnaround
it's his first bucket of the day one's
coming right back
another quick two there for cameron
johnson
two three seven nine sons kale bridges
on the tough drive
sons get the offensive rebound back to
cameron johnson and the rookie dropping
the three-point hit
[Music]
calling it alive to robertson javon
carter the bulldog comes up with a steal
kim johnson runs the floor takes the
payoff pass
and a look for the and one but i can
imagine you on the hard courts when you
were growing up if you fought that as
well
nice feet up top for deandre ayton for
the easy two
seven threes already being deposited
here for the thunder
cam johnson knocks down another one and
he'll look for the four point play
it wasn't here to start the game pam
johnson has seized the opportunity to
give that offensive
production for devin booker and again if
you're gonna call that
[Applause]
steps into the deep three and why not
wow
look at that i mean he said half court
and he shot it flat-footed
look it was like almost that's
ridiculous man
most people that far away gotta take a
dribble to be able to get some
power to to raise that's essentially the
equivalent
here these sons have faced in these
eight games
and they are extremely close to the
finish line as ayton
sprints right to the rim and gets the
feed from rubio for the first two of the
game
should feast against as kylo quinn gets
the first two points he has played
a grand total of five minutes and 39
seconds
in the bubble game as mikhail bridges
knifing right to the who a lot of the
reason is because they don't have their
normal stalwarts in there
ben simmons is one of the best defenders
in the league book with the blow by
gets the roll just off the
side of the iron
coming back the other way it doesn't
take a lot of shots so
you still have to respect them with that
stroke look good
shark is able to slip inside
able to turn the corner gets inside and
gets the and one opportunity
dario as he said ej this is
it under man team
is devon booker taking matter into his
own hands
sneaky athleticism sneaky he snuck them
that's when it just that's when it gets
you hurt because you don't think he's
going to do it
he laid it up about three or four times
going left
yeah court martial you're the highlight
man
smile for the camera
wouldn't leave that guy
nice feed over the top to the cutting
mchale bridges for the easy two
and if you don't think it can happen
well you haven't been watching games in
the ball
mentioned at the top no one even thought
nice defensive effort there by bridges
on the block shot on hardaway
mikael bridges gets it here comes rubio
dancing into curry and finding booker
inside with a nice feed
up his first for phoenix beautiful pass
here by rubio back
cut by booker to get on the
get that this is a straight magician
with the basketball
down the other way caught with a
beautiful athletic catch by cameron
johnson and quiets in for two
second best three-point shooting
percentage in history
after steve kerr nice stopping start
hooker puts it up and through booker
with it
played to kentucky for a season
at that getting started and he drops the
sledgehammer pretty play
by kevin booker the driver watch the
freeze move here little jab step
[Applause]
in a blink of an eye look at this pump
fake
comes curry the other way he'll dance
and feed and it's knocked away the quick
hands right there of cam johnson
he takes it and feeds on the wing carter
thinking three step back triple g
all the way back in trey burke back in
for dallas no porzingis because the
bruised heel for those of you just
joining us
nice hook pass inside he connects
and john look at this little touch pass
and how about the finish here
the top assist team in this bubble he
was always the last line of defense and
he was so
vocal good point what a pass lobbing it
in
ricky rubio and then you get rewarded at
the other end
and deandre ayden how about the great
hands here not good but
great hands deceptive move tap in try
right now ayton is there to vacuum it in
the other way they come that is a three
good he
cans it from outside they were perhaps
expecting
so many of these players have raised
their game like this kid right here
what a shot by booker hit the deck
hit the glass got it for two and a foul
look at this
waits for the defense comes on up there
look at the contact
here's curry outside hard away
thrashing inside great block inside by
eaton
uh they've gotten uh some gristle
probably
in them here comes a nice pass and it
goes from bridges
dayton
[Applause]
johnson got a hand on it
time he makes sure he finishes it with a
big block